قرية الكلى أو مستودع الكلى،
هي السوق السوداء الأشهر في العالم لبيع الكلى،
القرية التي وعد التجار سكانها
بأن كل كلية تستخرج منهم ستنمو بعد سنوات،
قرية فيها زبائن دائمون لشراء الكلى،
في هذه القرية هناك رحلات للهند
ومبالغ زهيدة ووعود وهمية،
خلال دقائق هذا الفيديو
سنرى (عندما يجتمع الجهل والفقر ما الذي يحدث؟)...
قرية الكلى أو القرية التي باع كل فرد من  سكانها كلية،
وتقع هذه القرية التي تدعى هوسكي، جنوب النيبال،
وتعتبر من بين أفقر القرى في العالم،
وأطلق عليها اسم قرية الكلى لأن كل سكانها يعيشون بكلية واحدة،،
وبينما يتردد تجار الأعضاء البشرية على هذه القرية
لإقناع مزيد من الأشخاص ببيع كِليهِم في السوق السوداء مقابل مبالغ مالية زهيدة
. ويتوجب على من يوافق على هذا النوع من "الصفقات"
التوجه الى الهند لإجراء العملية ثم العودة مجددا إلى القرية.
وعندما يذهبون إلى الهند بالتنقل عبر الجبال والأودية وطريق وعرة جدا،
يتم إجراء العمليات لهم ثم يعودون من الطريق ذاتها،
فمنهم من يقتله الإعياء والتعب جراء العملية،
ومنهم من يحدث له فشل لكليته الأخرى،
ومنهم من لا يستطيع العودة ويموت في الطريق، لكن ما هو المقابل؟. .
بعد أن يفقد الشخص في هذه القرية كليته،
ويخاطر بحياته، فهو سيحصل على مبلغ بقرابة الألف دولار فقط،
هذه القرية دفعها الفقر لذلك، حتى أن الشخص الذي لم يبع كليته
ينظر لجميع أصدقائه وقد باعوا كليهم،
فيقول لماذا أنا لا أبيع كليتي وأحصل على مبلغ من المال،
وأما التجار الذي يصلون لهذه القرية،
أي (تجار الموت، أو تجار الأعضاء البشرية)
فيستغلون جهل السكان، ويعدونهم بأن كليهم ستنمو بعد سنوات قليلة،
وهذا يجعل السكان يعتقدون أنهم لن يخسروا
بل على العكس، فستنمو كليهم مرة أخرى
وسيبيعونها مرة ثانية ليكسبوا المال،
..وبعد  بيع بعض السكان كليهم، لشراء منزل أو أراضٍ،
تضررت قريتهم جرّاء زلزال نيبال 2015
وتهدمت جميع منازلهم الطينية التي يبنونها بفتات المال
الذي يحصلون عليه من بيع الكلى، ...
فأين أصحاب حقوق الحيوان مما يعانيه الإنسان في هذه القرية؟...
ولا يزال الأمل يحدو البعض،
أن يأتي
من ينقذ سكان هذه القرية من جرائم تجار الأعضاء البشرية...